the many saints of newark the sopranos
prequel from writer producer david chase
and director alan taylor has finally
been released the movie follows the
complicated life of mobster dickie
moltesanti including his relationship
with young tony soprano and so far it
has proven a little divisive among
longtime fans of the landmark hbo series
sadly this probably isn't the kind of
buzz warner brothers was hoping for
after finally returning to david chase's
popular mob universe the movie is also
the latest experimental offering in the
dual release strategy warner brothers
has been deploying throughout the
pandemic some of the biggest most
anticipated releases distributed by the
studio have been given simultaneous day
and date debuts in theaters and on the
hbo max streaming service thus far the
experiment has been a mixed bag at least
as far as box office returns are
concerned some of these films have had
successful theatrical runs that haven't
been entirely cannibalized by their hbo
max releases including godzilla vs kong
and immortal combat but not all of
warner's films have been so successful
and the many states of newark has landed
squarely in the latter category oh my
god oh jesus
the many states of new york pulled in a
paltry five million dollars at the box
office in its first weekend of release
an underperformance even by the
diminished standards of pandemic era box
office pro projected before the weekend
that many saints would grow somewhere in
the range of 7 million to 12 million
dollars so why has this happened well
there's no smoking gun for why the
sopranos prequel didn't kill it at the
box office but it seems likely that a
combination of factors may have worked
together to reduce the movie's box
office takings according to a recent
analysis by deadline the main reason
could be that the target audience for
the many saints of newark is an older
demographic one that has been slow to
return to theaters over coronavirus
spheres the most successful films of the
pandemic era have been tentpole films
that appeal to younger viewers such as
black widow which grossed 80.8 million
dollars on its opening weekend
certainly it would be interesting to see
data on how many saints performed on hbo
max enough people may have watched it on
the streaming service for warner
brothers to be happy with it and hbo
just inked a massive new overall deal
with david chase 2 so they definitely
seem bullish on the potential for future
sopranos content nobody can really say
for sure whether the movie was a total
flop until those hbo figures are
released the other reason why the movie
might not be crushing at the box office
could be word of mouth there are a lot
of young soprano fans out there but they
didn't show up either the movie has a
mediocre c plus audience rating from
cinemascore and has gotten a lukewarm
response from sopranos fans on social
media if that's the case then any
sopranos fans who do want to check out
the new movie might do so on the
streaming service they already pay for
instead of shelling out for movie
tickets more than anything else however
there's a 250 pound symbiote-shaped
elephant in the room here a massive
rival to the many states of newark that
undeniably sucked up the box office
oxygen on this balmy october weekend
there's gonna be carnage
the many states of newark landed in
theaters and on hbo max on october 1st
the same day the woody harrelson and tom
hardy flick venom let there be carnage
got its release amid much fan
anticipation notably let there be
carnage did not receive a day and date
streaming release from sony pictures one
of the major studios most reluctant to
embrace the dual release strategy
preferred by warner brothers in disney
in the end sony's gamble on a pandemic
weekend at the theater paid off
dethroning black widow to become the
highest grossing theatrical release of
the pandemic era with so many moviegoers
flocking to see hardy's venom square off
against harrelson's carnage it seems
like there just wasn't much market share
left for many saints to claim
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you